only double jabbed people we haven't got
clarity on that yet have we
no and i imagine the prime minister will
either make a statement on this or be
asked about this at the press conference
but it's interesting that those covered
passports it was originally wasn't it
you had to have proof of vaccination
or proof of a negative covert test nadim
zahari the vaccines minister saying in
the comments there
that proof of a negative test will no
longer be
enough which says to me that the
government now really trying to compel
young people to get the vaccine they
need that wall
of vaccinated people to try and see off
this third wave which they expect to
peak in august but it's already really
taking off
now and it feels like freedom day has
come
but we are really a nation on edge
because no one really knows
how the next few weeks are going to pan
out so what do you think the tone will
be then it's
uh sir patrick valance the chief
scientific officer
advisor rather jonathan van tan the
deputy chief medical officer
and uh as i say remotely the prime
minister what what do you think we're
going to hear
i'm just looking trying to look through
my notes i think it will be a very
cautious tone
uh there have been a number of
scientists in recent days that have
warned about unlocking about going
slowly about
caution chris whittie has been saying
this hasn't he
very explicitly over the past couple of
weeks and i think the message will be
it might be freedom day but please
please be cautious you already saw that
the prime minister
performed an about turn two on the use
of masks
a few days ago he said it was suggested
you could wear a mask
if you so chose only then a week ago or
so to say that he now expected
people to wear masks in crowded places
so the government already move in
on the issue of masks we can see here
from what nadeem sahar we said
there's movement too uncovered passport
so a carefully
uh cautious irreversible path out of
lockdown is what it was billed as
but it now seems like the government is
taking policy decisions
almost on the hoof changing the guidance
changing expectations you saw what
happened in terms of france and changing
the rules around that as they struggle
to grapple
with these rising cases now the key
thing is
do the rise in transmission of the virus
lead to more hospitalizations yes they
do but what happens
to those needing to go into intensive
care and indeed the death rate key to
all of this
is the government being able to manage
increasing transmission
without the nhs being overwhelmed chris
whittie the chief medical officer
said a week ago that he was hopeful if
we proceeded out of lockdown cautiously
that the nhs would be okay that it
wouldn't be overwhelmed
but that was the test on which he was
nervous
and now it seems like the cases are
really rising what impact does it have
on the nhs and will the government have
to reverse i think that's certainly
the expectation of kirsten with the
labour leader who has called this plan
reckless he's called on the government
to make changes such as making
face masks mass mandatory uh because
labour think that the government will
have to reverse some of these steps out
of lockdown
yeah and i mean you mentioned it there
this watch word or previously it was a
watch word irreversible now
do you think there has been a shift then
and maybe an acceptance that
some restrictions may have to be
reimposed i think that has mark if you
think about when the prime minister
called it a cautious irreversible route
out of lockdown that was back in
february when he announced
uh the road maps so much has changed
since then and
the one thing that we have become clear
and clear about is that you can't
really manage i'm going to interrupt you
yeah yeah i'm going to interrupt you and
we're going to listen to uh okay boris
johnson good afternoon everybody thank
you very much
uh for joining uh sir patrick and uh
jonathan van tan in london and me
uh here in isolation in buckinghamshire
today
we've reached the fourth step on our
roadmap
and i know that the case is increasing
steadily
and with more and more people being
asked to self-isolate
there will of course be those uh who
would rather that we'd
waited weeks or months longer and kept
on social distancing and all the legal
restrictions that we've been placing on
our lives
and so i want to remind you all
why i believe that it's like to take
this
step now no matter how difficult it
seems and
the logic remains the same but if we
don't
open up now then we face a risk of even
tougher conditions in the colder months
when the virus
has a natural advantage we lose that
far break of the school holidays and
there comes a point after so many
have been vaccinated when further
restrictions no longer
prevent hospitalizations and deaths
but simply delay the inevitable
and so we have to ask ourselves the
question
if not now when and though both
deaths and hospitalizations as i say are
sadly rising
these numbers are well within the
margins of what our scientists predicted
at the outset
of the roadmap and so it is right to
proceed cautiously
in the way that we are but it's also
right
to recognize that this pandemic is far
from over and that's why i'm afraid it
is
essential to keep up the system of test
face and isolate and i know how
frustrating it is for all those who have
been affected or pinged
and i want to explain therefore
that people identified as contacts of
cases
are at least five times more likely
to be infected than others and
even if they've been vaccinated there is
a significant risk
that they can still pass the disease on
and so as we go forward i'm afraid
that the continuing sacrifice of this
large minority those of us who are being
asked to isolate
remains important to allow the rest of
society
to get back to something like normality
and i'm afraid at this stage it's simply
a consequence of living with kogit
and of opening up when cases are high in
the way
that we are as you know we'll be moving
on august the 16th to a system of
testing
rather than isolation for those who are
double vaccinated by which time of
course we hope that the
wall of immunity in our country will be
even higher
and in the meantime i want to
assure you that we will protect crucial
services including the staffing of our
hospitals and our
our care homes the supplies of food
water electricity
and medicines the running of our trains
the
protection of our borders the defense of
our realm by making sure that
a small number very small number of
named
fully vaccinated critical workers
are able to lead their isolation
solely for the work that i have
described
but for the vast majority of us myself
included we do need
to stick with the system for now and
of course the only reason that we're
able to open up in this way
at all is that we've vaccinated such a
large
proportion of the population and at
such speed it is phenomenal that every
adult in this country has now been
offered
a first dose but unfortunately
that does not mean that every person
over 18
has yet had a first dose so far
96 of over 50s 83
of 30 to 50 year olds have taken up the
offer
in england but there are still 35
of 18 to 30 year olds at 3 million
people
who are at the moment completely
unvaccinated
and we can all see the enthusiasm of
millions
of young people to get their jabs
we need even more young adults
to receive a protection that is of
immense benefit
to your family and friends and to
yourselves
and so i would remind everybody that
some of life's most
important pleasures and opportunities
are likely to be increasingly dependent
on vaccination
there are already countries that require
you
already to be double jabbed as a
condition
of quarantine free travel and i'm afraid
that list
seems likely to grow and we're also
concerned as they are in other countries
by the continuing risk posed by
nightclubs i don't want to have to close
nightclubs again as they have elsewhere
but it does mean nightclubs need to do
the socially responsible thing
and that use of the nhs coded past which
shows
proof of vaccination a really a recent
negative test or natural immunity as a
means
of entry as we said last week
we do reserve the right to mandate
certification
at any point if it's necessary to reduce
transmission and i should serve notice
now that by the end of september when
all over 18's will have had their chance
to be double jabbed we're planning to
make
full vaccination the condition of entry
to
nightclubs and other venues where large
crowds gather
proof of a negative test will no longer
be enough now let me stress
we want people to be able to take back
their freedoms as they can today
we want this country to be able to enjoy
the fruits
of our massive efforts and of our
enormous
vaccination campaign but to do that
we must remain cautious
and we must continue to get vaccinated
and that's why
we're asking you to come forward and get
your jabs
now thank you all very much i'll now ask
patrick to do this thank you very much
can i have the first slide please
we have high levels of covid and they
are increasing and this slide shows the
number of people testing positive for
covid in the uk
from the first of september through to
now and you can see the size of the
awesome wave then the winter wave
and then on the right hand side of the
slide where we are now
whereas in the winter wave we were up to
around 60 000
people testing positive per day we are
now
somewhere up towards 50 000. so we're
quite close to the size of the winter
wave of infections
and this is going to increase and step
four
is a big inside mixing step so it will
increase
further as we go into step four
the risks of high prevalence high
numbers of cases
are really four major risks the first of
course that that translates to some
extent through to hospitalizations and
deaths which i will talk about more
that's protected by the vaccine but not
completely
the second is of course there will be an
increased risk of long-term
complications so-called long-covid
the third is that the high levels of
infection
as the virus replicates it makes
mistakes
and those mistakes are what cause
variance to occur
and the fourth is because of high levels
of infection you have a high
number of people who therefore pinged
and off work
and it affects the workforce so there
are four strong reasons
for worrying about high infection rates
and the fifth is that
the testing process of course becomes
very stretched at high levels
of infection so we have high levels of
infection that are rising
and will be expected to continue to rise
next slide please
when we look at the number of people in
hospital with kovid
it's a somewhat different picture so the
first peak
second peak you can see clearly and then
on the right hand side you can see that
the number of people in hospital is
increasing
so it can it will increase because of
the infections but not as far as it did
before
and that is because of the protection of
the vaccines
so we do expect this number to increase
we do expect there to be over a thousand
people per day
being hospitalized with covid because of
the increased infections
but the rate should be lower than they
have been previously
because of the protective effects of
vaccination and the real importance of
making sure that everybody gets
vaccinated
next slide please if you look at the
curves of death then that's even lower
and you can see again the autumn wave
and the winter wave with unfortunately
large numbers of people
who succumbed to coveted infection and
you can see in the dotted line
the size of the first peak back to
last year we are seeing an increase in
the number of deaths but at a much much
lower level
but they again will continue to increase
as infections increase
and will be expected to reach over 100
possibly
a lot over 100 but but we'll see an
increase in deaths over the next
few weeks as the infections rise but at
a much lower level again
because of the protection of vaccination
next slide please this tries to lay that
out in a slightly different way
so the autumn wave is in orange and the
current wave is in blue
and the curves for the two waves have
just been overlaid
and the axis that goes up is is showing
you the number of increasing cases or
the number of increases in admissions or
deaths
and along the bottom is the number of
days since the start of the wave
and what you can see is a very close
increase
overlap of cases increasing very similar
between the autumn wave and the current
wave and you can see the autumn wave
then topped out at slightly lower levels
when you look at admissions the number
of admissions was higher
in the autumn wave and went up
sooner and with deaths it went up
sooner is much steeper and
went to much higher levels than we're
seeing now so this
again confirms the crucial importance of
vaccination
in protecting against the effects of the
infection
as well as reducing amongst the
population
the chance of becoming infected next
slide please even with this more
more um transmissible variant that we
have now
in terms of the vaccination profile the
prime minister has mentioned this
a large number of people have been
vaccinated um
something like 88 of the popular adult
population
has had one dose and 68.5 percent have
had two doses so large numbers have been
vaccinated
but of course it means that large
numbers also
have not been vaccinated there's still
people in their 20s and 30s who have not
yet been vaccinated and we need to make
sure that happens
so the messages are first that the
number of cases
is high and increasing so that is a risk
and we need to be aware of it
secondly in order to try to reduce the
chance of spreading infection it's
important that we stay
cautious we go very slowly with the
opening up
and that people retain that distance and
risk risk appetite not to go into places
where you're going to have a high risk
of infection
so that we try and keep the levels down
and third the vaccination is crucial
and that the vaccination of course is
crucial for all the age groups who are
eligible
and it's important that we see the
uptake in the younger age groups as well
as continued um presence of giving
vaccines to people who are older who
haven't yet been vaccinated
thank you prime minister thank you very
much patrick let's get you
to the public first toby from southern
colorado
so i've been studying abroad for much of
this last year which meant that
i've been fully vaccinated in italy
rather than the uk
while i have proof of vaccination and an
eu green pass
i can't get the nhs kovid pass for
events
nor can i travel abroad to amber
countries without quarantine
what's been done to help recognize the
vaccinated status of
people like me
toby i'm going to ask jdt to uh george
pantan to
uh address this as well but obviously
we're working with
uh partners around the world to make
sure that we understand the efficacy of
their
their vaccines and have mutual
recognition for for all efficacious
vaccines
as fast as possible but um jbt perhaps
you could say a bit more
yeah thanks prime minister thanks for
the question toby
so um the point you're making is a
perfectly reasonable one
that if you've had a good vaccine in
another country then
that vaccine is going to be just as
good for you and give you just as much
protection as the vaccines we are giving
people
here in the uk and there is a great deal
of awareness
amongst my policy colleagues in
government about this
and there's a lot of work going on to
sort this out
but it has to be done in a rational
careful way
and it has to be fair for all and we're
working as hard as we can to get there
thanks very much jbt and david from
rocher
out of all the announced daily covet
cases
what percentage of these have had none
one
or both of their vaccination injections
right that is a very good question i
think sadly the number of
uh kobe cases that uh have
uh involved somebody who's had two
vaccinations has been
has been rising although clearly the
results the
the of the vaccines remain very good in
the sense that they protect
those people very largely against
serious illness and death even if they
uh even if they contract it but
on the exact figures i wonder whether uh
patrick
you you have something to add there well
in terms of the number of people in
hospital
who've been double vaccinated we know
it's around 60 percent of the people
being admitted to hospital with covid
have been double vaccinated
and that's not surprising because the
vaccines are not
100 effective they're very very
effective but not 100
and as a higher proportion of the
population is double vaccinated
it's inevitable that those
10 of that very large number remain at
risk and therefore will be amongst the
people who both catch
the infection and end up in hospital so
whilst
vaccines are very effective at reducing
severe disease
they're also effective at reducing the
chance of catching it
and reducing the chance of passing it on
but they're slightly less effective at
doing that than they are preventing
severe disease
and so uh what we will see
as we get the let's say everybody
if everybody over the 18 had taken up
the vaccine then of course
anybody who caught it would be double
vaccinated so the answer is that we
should expect to see
a higher proportion of people in
hospital
and catching the infection who are
double vaccinated that is inevitable
that we will see that
because of the um not
uh the less than 100 efficacy of the
vaccines overall
thanks very much patrick uh let's go
to fergus walk bbc
are you effectively giving people an
ultimatum
get vaccinated soon or you'll be denied
entry
to crowded venues added venues and
to the scientists how concerned are you
for the potential
of super spreader events in nightclubs
and pubs where there is no social
distancing now
fergus i want to make one thing
absolutely clear young
people have been absolutely heroic
throughout this
pandemic and they've uh they've made
enormous sacrifices
in their lives very largely to protect
uh the vulnerable protector the older
generation to protect the nhs they faced
huge restrictions on on their liberties
and i've got
you know boundless admiration for what
they uh they've done the character
that they they have shown and we've got
to make sure that we
allow that younger generation to bounce
back as
as quickly and as fast as we possibly
can i think one thing that would really
help
would it would be if we can continue to
reduce the time that we're all living
under this
pandemic and the best way to do that is
if we all get
vaccinated as as fast as possible and
the offer is there
and by today uh july the 19th everybody
has had an offer over 18 to to get a
vaccine
uh three three million uh of the 18 to
year old group have yet to take it up
all we're saying is come on folks
this is it uh you won't regret it uh
it's the right thing
to do for uh for you uh
for your family and for everybody else
above all it's the right thing
uh for you to take back you know to help
get back the freedoms you love
i think a question about super spreading
events and oliver go and then
jonathan may want to to add add to this
right the way across the world we've
seen that
nightclubs and venues where you've got
lots of people
indoors crowded together
are a focus for potential super
spreading events
um and that has also been seen in terms
of what's happened in holland and israel
where nightclubs opened and you saw a
big increase in cases
so i think it's there's no question that
that is an environment in which
spreading is easier you've got lots of
people
quite close together you've got the
environment in which spreading becomes
easier and
i would expect with opening of
nightclubs we'll continue to see an
increase in cases
and we will see outbreaks related to
specific nightclubs as well
and that's again why it's so important
that everybody
comes and gets a vaccine um so that we
can reduce the chance of spread and we
can reduce the chance of
consequences of that spread thanks
patrick so i'll just go back to what
i've said
at this podium more than once before
that um the principles of how
covid and other respiratory viruses
spread um follows the um
the japanese three seas which the
japanese government have used
to advise their citizens from the outset
of this pandemic see number one
closed settings where the ventilation is
relatively low
see number two crowded settings where
there are a lot of people per square
meter basically
see number three close social contact
if that's the purpose of being there
particularly and particularly if it's
strangers or people you don't normally
mix with
now i don't particularly think it's
helpful to pick out a particular type of
building
or a particular type of business
i could create the japanese three c's by
inviting a load of strangers into a
garden shed
and sitting around having a beer with
the door shut that would do it
that is the japanese three c's
encapsulated
so those are the things that as
scientists
we are concerned about wherever they
occur
and under whatever circumstances
thanks very much thanks very much um
down here at itv
thank you prime minister and you all
said the road map was
cautious but irreversible it's so much
uncertain
over how high infection rates and
hospitalizations could get do you can
see that it's now a promise
that you can no longer keep that you may
have to at some point
reimpose these restrictions later in the
year
thanks stan yeah thanks for asking that
because
i want to repeat really what i said last
week and i think but perhaps the week
before about this
the the road map is we hope irreversible
i think i said that from the
from the get-go but we can't guarantee
that something
could obviously happen that changes our
our calculations
and we we've got to be humble in the
face of of nature
uh there could be some new uh mutant to
some units a new variant of the virus
that
we have to respond to in a particular
way i've always been
very clear about that the only way we
can make the
road map irreversible dan is by
continuing
uh to be cautious and that i'm afraid is
why
uh we've got to continue with the
measures that we are
uh but continue with the uh the the
routines that we have the test trace
and isolate but above all why we've got
to continue to focus
uh as uh as jvt and patrick have said on
that vaccination
campaign and get your jab
uh tom newton down times radios
thank you prime minister a question to
sir patrick and jonathan van tam
first uh the the success of step four
would seem to depend
on when the peak arrives and when it
starts decreasing at a time which no one
really seems to be clear there's been
estimates of mid-august aspen's end of
august
is it right to say that the next crucial
date we should all look out for
is the beginning of september when
schools start to come back because if
cases
haven't started to decrease by then
we're still rising
then that would have to be the moment
you'd need to step in and reduce
transmission
by imposing restrictions again and to
the prime minister
your announcement just now on mass
events uh vaccination passports is magic
for mass events
what other mass events are you thinking
about what about football stadiums would
they be
imaginative there a lot of enclosed
spaces at halftime are you getting a
burger
up the emirates for example you're very
packed in uh
and if you're going to do this why not
do it now why wait till september why
give 10 weeks
of mass spreading because nightclubs
have already told you they're not going
to do this
uh thanks is it crystal pack because
you're going to go first please
sorry well may want to come in as well
on this
um the timing of the um
peak is uncertain as you rightly say
um and uh it varies in the models
um over over august at different times
and it
could even be you get a peak and then it
goes down it comes back up again
a little bit as as as the step four
effects kick
in so that's really quite uncertain um
but most of the models are suggesting
that there should be a peak and start
seeing some sort of either plateau or
decrease over
over august um and at that point
if if things continue to increase at the
rate they are and as i said at the
outset
there is something like 50 000 or near
50 000
uh cases per day or
positives per day at the moment being
detected with a doubling time of 11 days
you can see that that gets to pretty
high numbers very quickly and
another doubling time would take you to
even higher numbers of course that would
be
really quite um quite worrying so we
would like to see
some flattening of this some decrease in
the trajectory
and ideally as you rightly say you'd
like to see this
coming down by september
as return of schools would add another
pressure on top of that
yeah thanks patrick so what i'd really
add to that is
this huge uncertainty about how high the
peak will be
tom and how long it's going to take us
to get there
but the reason why the modelers tell us
there is this uncertainty at the moment
is because
so much of it is going to be driven by
human behavior
over the next four to six weeks so
really it is kind of in everybody's
hands yours in mind
if we are gradual and cautious
and we don't tear the pants out of this
just because we're
glad to have our full freedoms back then
we will materially affect the size and
shape
of the remainder of this epidemic curve
and where the peak occurs
and how big it is it is literally in
the hands of the public in terms of the
behaviors and i would just urge
um people to be gradual and people to be
cautious
to the extent possible that doesn't mean
you can't have fun i was back at the
boston united news stadium
on saturday having a bit of fun it can
be done
but gradually and cautiously please
i i want to echo that completely i think
jbt
is has totally uh summed it up and just
on the point about
uh nightclubs i don't particularly want
to single out any
uh sector or business tom but
as i said earlier on there are uh there
is evidence from other countries that
have had a particular problem with the
uh the opening up of nightclubs so what
we're repeating today is we want
nightclubs to
uh behave responsibly use the uh
the kobit nhs app uh we'll we will
reserve the right to go to mandation for
that
if we uh if we have to and um
we you may may well want to change
to a a certification regime for
for that kind of setting for nightclubs
um once everybody over 18 has had the
opportunity to get
uh two jabs which will be uh by the end
of september and
uh i i do think that that's a a sensible
approach but on the other hand we don't
want
uh now as you suggested to simply to
to close nightclubs or to keep them
closed i don't think that that would be
the right thing to do
to get back to what i said earlier in
the argument
um you have to ask yourself if not now
when we have the
the opportunity now the fire break of
the of the school holidays
plus we have the the risk of opening up
in
the uh the the colder months and the
the point of the epidemic at this stage
or the
the feature of the epidemic at this
stage now that so many people
have been vaccinated is that if you keep
on
uh restrictions all you're really doing
in a way is uh is not not preventing
uh hospitalizations uh but you're simply
postponing them so
you'll get back to the if not now when
uh argument
tom uh it is a it is a difficult
judgment but we have to proceed
uh cautiously in the way uh that
the jbt has i think really perfectly
laid out
um harry cole of the sun
thank you prime minister um a question
for professor van tam um you repeated
your famous plea there not to tear the
pants off of lock down lifting
what's your response to the images we've
seen over the last few days of packed
beaches and nightclubs and parks
and crowds and the the scenes we saw
around the euros finals
are we already tearing the pants off it
and are you worried yet
and prime minister a couple of things if
i may um you've spoken today about the
importance of everyone playing their
part
sticking with the system and isolating
so why on earth did you think you were
above the rules on saturday what was
going on there
and on vaccine passports is this just
the thinner
than a thin end of the wedge you've
previously ruled out
vaccine passports or pubs can you
definitively say
you will never be asked to show your
papers to get a pint
in a pub this year and on a slightly
different subject
uh just while we've got you on the
record um very simply
does your 2019 manifesto commitment not
to raise national insurance
or income tax still stand
okay uh a lot of good good stuff for me
there
but i think jbt you were going first my
question was about beaches
parks and nightclubs um and some of the
uh
scenes of crowding i guess we've seen in
the last few days
so um two of the settings you've
mentioned are outdoors
with lots of ventilation with lots of
ultraviolet light
and therefore a much much safer
environment
in terms of the era biology of covid 19
and indeed other respiratory viruses and
the other one you mentioned is a closed
indoor setting
very strongly associated with deliberate
close
social contact um the consumption of
alcohol quite often
and um late in the evening so they are
rather different
um am i worried about it i think i want
everybody
to go cautiously and gradually
and i think a lot of people in the uk a
lot of ordinary citizens
see the case rates high see that at the
moment
although hospitalizations are increasing
and there
are significant parts of the northwest
and the northeast of the nhs that
would tell you now they're on under
quite a bit of pressure again
um from covid so citizens are worried
about this
and i think they get it by and large
that it's really important
to go slowly and to go gradually at this
and
our destiny is very largely in our own
hands in two ways
how gradually and cautious we are and
how
well we can finish the job of the
vaccination program in adults
it's as simple as that and a lot a lot
of people already have said i mean a
vast majority actually they
intend to continue wearing masks in
indoor indoor spaces where they might
come into contact with people so i think
the caution as jonathan has said is
there in the way people
intend to behave
brilliant oh thanks thanks very much uh
harry look up on your on your first
point
i know of course i absolutely didn't
think that and uh here i am
uh today on zoom or teams or or whatever
brilliant system that
it is that we're uh that we're using
secondly you asked about
uh about pubs and um
i i don't want to get as i said many
times before in this pandemic i don't
want to get a situation where
uh people are asked to produce papers uh
to go anywhere to do and do
any enjoy any of the pleasures that they
do uh but
uh we've got to make sure that we and so
i certainly don't want to see
uh pubs uh passports for for pubs
uh but uh whether
the settings that uh the jbt describes
uh as conforming to the corresponding to
the three
c's uh closed crowded with close uh
social contact
uh you know we we reserve a right to do
what's necessary to
to protect the the public and on your
final point about
fiscal uh measures uh which i think may
be a
a brilliantly veiled question uh on
the um the long-awaited plans to
deal with uh the the problem of
of social care and how to how to cover
all that and
uh health care as well uh problem that
is
the devil governments for at least three
decades all i can say harry is uh we
waited
uh three decades uh you you're just
going to wait a little bit
longer i'm sorry about that but it won't
be too long it won't be too long now i
assure you
um george parker financial times
thank you prime minister it's a question
for all three of the speakers
first question to patrick valance i
think you mentioned earlier that some
indicate in the instance where there are
very high number of cases
that testing becomes stretched i wonder
if you could elaborate on that
do we have enough lateral flow tests and
do we have enough pcr tests
to see us through this very difficult
period ahead a question for jonathan van
tam
back on the nightclub's question you'll
know very well that in the netherlands
they
allowed nightclubs to reopen and then a
few weeks later they had to close them
the prime minister mark rutter
apologized he said the government had
made a mistake
it's a very straight question for you
bearing in mind what you were saying
earlier about the three c's
do you think that nightclubs should be
reopening in this country
now uh and finally a question to the
prime minister just like to ask you a
little bit more about the exemptions
you've announced to the self-isolation
policy uh you all have heard lord
bilimori of the cbi president saying
today that
the exemptions were causing uh crippling
the economy
in every sector can you just describe in
a bit more detail which sectors you
think should be exempt
and would you hesitate to extend that
list of exemptions
if serious economic disruption was being
caused
thanks uh i'll go last call yes
the point about testing is is really
two-fold
one is just numbers of tests and an
ability to use them but the second is
the whole system
comes under strain obviously the the
larger the numbers the more difficult it
is to actually make sure everybody does
get tested
and i've said before that things like
test trace and isolate
are most effective when numbers are low
actually and they become
increasingly difficult to operationalize
when cases
are high so i think that's really the
combination of those things is what puts
uh testing under pressure as numbers go
up and it depends of course how high
they go as to how much pressure
ultimately it comes into so i think
that's what we need to watch out for
as numbers continue to increase
so i thanks for the question i
have young adults who are my friends and
parts of my family
and um they like socializing and they
like partying that's
clear um they have also
in some cases and i'm not referring now
to my family but i i'm referring
to um young people in general because of
the sacrifices essentially they have
made
for the older populations in the uk
to lock down and prevent those
catastrophic levels of
of hospitalization and dying in the
elderly they have made sacrifices
in terms of the kind of social
interactions they can have
and in terms of the relationships they
can be building at a time
when young people want to and have
the absolute right to build
relationships for the future
so i completely sympathize with that
on the science side however it is a case
in point
that if you pack my garden shed full of
people
and they are unvaccinated the likelihood
of transmission
is going to be far greater than if you
pack my garden shed
full of people who have been fully
vaccinated
and have are 14 days out the other side
of their second dose
it will not reduce the risks to zero
nothing reduces the risks to zero other
than standing in a
um a meadow completely on your own at
infinitum
with nobody coming within you know three
metres of you
but it is a case in point that
epidemiologically
and scientifically the rest on the
policy side is for ministers
but epidemiologically vaccinated groups
of people are
generally safer on transmission terms
than
unvaccinated people i'm sure patrick
would agree with that
thanks very much jbt and uh just on on
your your points
about uh karen bellamore in the and the
cbi
karen's absolutely right to draw
attention to this disruption that
businesses are facing uh everybody
is uh being uh inundated with
uh appeals for uh us to end the pingings
to end the
uh test tracing is my totally understand
that uh
the list i've read out of the uh
of the sectors that are absolutely
crucial for our country that will be
able to
get on on different arrangements uh
sectors there but we we don't want to
extend it
too widely obviously um george because
this is one of the few shots we've got
left in our locker one of the only shots
we've got left in our
locker to stop the the chain reaction of
the spread of
of code and you've heard the the
statistics uh
you're you're five times more likely to
catch it if you're
a contact of someone who has it and even
if you've been
uh vaccinated you're still capable of
spreading it so there are sound
epidemiological
reasons now uh for keeping cautious and
i'm afraid that's what we've
got to do i know how frustrating it is
for people but we will be moving once
we've got more people vaccinated
on august the 16th we will be moving
to a a different regime
based on uh on testing rather
than isolation i know that's a while uh
to wait but
uh this was never going to be an easy uh
period we're
opening up now in a in a surge of
infections and we can only do it
because we've uh we've vaccinated so
many people
the answer is plea please follow the
recommendations of nhs
test and trace and uh please get a jab
uh paul
war hug post
thank you first to professor van tam
last week chris whittie said the number
of people hospitalized could hit quotes
pretty scary numbers if the trend
continues
if rising hospitalizations do pose a
risk at the end to the nhs
what would be the first restrictions
you'd be tempted to reapply that would
have the most proportionate and
immediate impact
and to sir patrick no countries relax
relaxations
restrictions as cases are rising so
rapidly as they are here
um do you want do you think we should
level with the public that this is
essentially a huge experiment and that
they're the guinea pigs
and prime minister finally sir jeremy
farah a member of sage has said today
it's a disgrace that the public inquiry
into the pandemic won't start until next
year at the earliest
he said there's absolutely no reason for
the delay other than political
maneuvering
is he right
uh patrick and jamie tina are code
questions to me and i think for once i
probably got the easy question
on hospitalizations um
we are in a situation now where the nhs
is not on in at the moment anything like
the pressure that it was back in january
and february
but today is the day when society opens
up
the knock-on effect on infections will
be
seven to ten days from now before we can
even really see
much of a flicker of the impact of that
and then we'll have to wait another
seven to ten days after that
to see the impact on hospitalizations
but all the predictions are
that if cases continue to rise there
will be increased
pressure on hospitals and what the nhs
has
in front of it now is not only dealing
with these new hospitalizations
but also dealing with the catch-up
of other care that it needs to
now provide that it couldn't when
frankly there were times when the nhs
could do very little
other than care for patients with covid
because it was so overworked
and on top of that of course hospital
staff
healthcare staff primary care too across
the whole
gamut you know these heroes have been
flat out for 18 months and they are
tired
people i have to say that i know that so
all those
factors are important in terms of
hospitalizations
and then in terms of well what would we
do if we got into a position
where um you know we were in that
situation
um i think that's something that
absolutely would go back
to sage for consideration but i think we
know
that what puts the pressure back on
an upward um pressure back on are
is close contact indoors that
in it indoor things that are the worst
things and that's one of the reasons why
right now with the weather as it is in
the summer ahead of us
you know now is if there is a good time
and you know it's
there's no such thing as a sweet spot
i'm afraid with covered 19
but if there is a sweet spot um going
into the summer
when many of the things we like doing
can be done outdoors
um is probably a good place to be right
now
patrick thank you it's not possible to
open up
without cases going up and so that's an
inevitable consequence and if you look
back at the
road map right from february and the
modeling it
predicted that levels would go go up
following step three and then go up
further following step four
so where we are is where you would
expect to be
as you begin to open up even with a
heavily vaccinated
uh population and that has been of
course and then amplified
by the presence of the delta variant
which is much more transmissible
so we are now in a situation as i said
earlier with
high case levels that will increase
further
and opening up will increase that again
because of the
big indoor step associated with step
four
the models all show that if you go more
slowly and it comes back to the point
you've said repeatedly go
very cautiously slowly change behavior
slowly avoid the sorts of environments
where you're going to get more spread
and be careful then the size of the peak
will be lower
but the opening up into an increasing
wave
does carry specific risks of increased
infection which is then mitigated
by uh the presence of vaccinations and
the sorts of numbers that
the models are saying is very likely
we'll get to above a thousand
hospitalizations today it could be
uh uh quite a lot higher than that um
and there will be deaths of course
associated with that so i think it's
laid out very clearly in the papers as
to what the risks
are associated with that and opening up
into an increasing wave
as predicted will lead to a further
increase i think that's very clear
that's very clear thanks
uh very much and uh paul i don't really
answer
the point made by uh
a brilliant public scientist with the
observation just now another
brilliant public scientist uh jonathan
van tan which is this
we're still right now working uh flat
out at least
the nhs he's working absolutely flat out
we're in the
middle of a of a third uh not
insignificant
wave of coded and i i just don't think
this is the right time
to ask so many leading public officials
uh to concentrate so much of their
energy
and and mental space uh to a public
inquiry but
i do think that next spring i will be uh
as far as i can tell look at the
epidemic i think that almost certainly
will be
the right time and we will go it will be
a full proper uh public inquiry
but i wanted to stress to you paul and
to all our viewers that we
continue to learn lessons the whole time
okay everybody thanks to patrick and to
jonathan van tan
and thank you all very much for watching
well there we are boris johnson from
isolation at checkers saying we will
proceed
cautiously but it is clear that the
pandemic is far from over and then he
made a
a plea to the young the uh those aged
between
um 18 to 30 to get uh jab
96 of over 50 has been double jabbed 83
percent of 50
to 80s have been double jabbed but far
fewer younger adults and he reminded
them that
he said many of life's pleasures as he
put it that's what he said including
nightclubs
uh would require from the end of
september two jabs
and a covered passport in effect to gain
entry nightclubs and other venues of
large crowds was how he described it
so an ultimatum of sorts i suppose to
young people and then a rather stark
statistic from patrick valance saying
60 percent of people being admitted to
hospital with covid
have had two doses of the vaccine so uh
that's what we
heard let's talk to our political editor
beth rigby who was
listening to that so beth um a word
first on this
clear plan from the end of september for
covid passports for nightclubs at least
yes mark i think there was a couple of
things in there the prime minister
pressing ahead repeating his mantra now
if not now
then where when but what a dose of
caution
he injected into that what i noticed was
now a plan to make covered passports
mandatory
by the end of september for nightclubs
and other big
venues that was not on the table just
days
ago is that because the prime minister
is now trying to compel
young people to get the vaccine that's
jittery to me that sounds like
he needs to try and pull policy leavers
to try and get the young
uh vaccinated and when was asked by
george parker of the ft
uh about lifting the isolation rules
which are now due to be lifted on august
the 16th he said it was one of the only
shots we've got left
in our locker to stop the chain reaction
of the speed
of covid now if that doesn't sound like
a nervous
prime minister uh to you i don't know
what a nervous prime minister sounds
like he's literally trying to find ways
to try and limit transmission all the
while
insisting that he must open up that now
is the time but listen too to what sir
patrick said
right at the end of that press
conference he said
we have high case levels they will
increase further
when we open up into these large indoor
gatherings they will increase
again he said models show that if you go
slowly
uh to avoid those sorts of environments
the peak of this virus will be lower but
clearly the government has decided not
to do that patrick valens himself
himself saying that nightclubs are super
spreading
events so that's where we are the
government now looking at
isolation and mandatory passports to try
and limit
transmission as part of things in their
toolkits but is it enough
or will it look in a few weeks time that
the wrong decisions were made right at
this moment on freedom day
yeah and noticeable that he said in
answer to a question about this
idea of irreversible he said we hope
the road map is irreversible but clearly
we cannot guarantee that
yeah the language around irreversibility
has changed
somewhat in recent weeks he made that
cautious but irreversible pledge back in
february
he said more recently that he hopes to
be able
to recommit to that but it depends on
what the virus does and
if you think about it to to make that
sort of promise anyway with a virus that
can mutate
that can change that you can't really
control was perhaps not the wisest
thing to promise and he's certainly
trying to drop that language now and why
because he simply can't predict what
will happen in the coming weeks it
really is going to be a bit of a squeaky
bum time i think for the government
right so just um 45 seconds or a minute
left
at beth until the top of the hour so
where do you think we are then
um this was you know so-called freedom
day where do you
having listened to that where do you
think we are i think it's
a nervous freedom day in that the cases
are rising
uh quickly uh patrick valance there
talking about a thousand
hospitalizations or more a day that
there will be
deaths that the peak could be high the
gambilis
that enough people will be vaccinated by
mid-august that
that it peaks the virus peaks and then
it begins
to tear off but there's no
predictability around that and yet the
government is continuing to reopen no
mandatory face
masks no mandatory passports for
nightclubs until
two months down the line and if they get
that calculation wrong
it's going to be very politically
difficult for boris johnson
okay beth thanks very much indeed
certainly a lot
in that news conference to digest beth
thank you very much
for that this is the newshour
coming up no nightclub admission to the
unjab
the government's attempt to get the
young to take up the vaccine much more
[Music]
next
pogito
[Music]
this is the newshour at six i'm mark
austin coming up in the next 60 minutes
if your jab's not done you're not coming
in vaccine passports to be compulsory
for
nightclubs from september i would remind
everybody that some of
life's most important pleasures and
opportunities
are likely to be increasingly dependent
on
vaccination and confirmation that sixty
percent
of those admitted to hospital have had
both covered jabs
also at six covent takes its toll on
team gb just four days before the tokyo
olympics begin
and in the daily climate show scenes of
devastation across germany and belgium
as the deadly floods recede while the uk
heat wave prompts the met office to
issue its first ever
extreme heat warning
[Music]
good evening if you want to go to a
nightclub after september you'll need to
be double vaccinated against covid
addressing the nation from isolation at
checkers the prime minister insisted it
wasn't
an ultimatum but it certainly marks a
shift in focus away from older people
and onto the younger members of society
the news conference also revealed that
60 percent of those currently being
admitted to hospital
have had two jabs we'll be discussing
that with our science correspondent in
just a moment but first let's listen to
what boris johnson
had to say we need even more
young adults to receive a protection
that is of immense benefit to your
family and friends
and to yourselves and so i would remind
everybody that some of
life's most important pleasures and
opportunities
are likely uh to be increasingly
dependent on
vaccination we do reserve the right to
mandate certification at any point if
it's necessary
to reduce transmission i should serve
notice now that
by the end of september when all over
18's
will have had their chance to be double
jabbed
we're planning to make full vaccination
the condition of entry to
nightclubs and other venues where large
crowds gather
proof of a negative test will no longer
be enough let's bring in our political
correspondent kate mccann
who is at uh westminster good evening
kate so this certainly wasn't how the
prime minister wanted it to be
talking there from isolation at checkers
and it was a news conference of
you know of caution and concern and this
whole idea of course of covered
passports for
uh people wanting to go into nightclubs
yeah you're right when you say that it's
not how boris johnson would have wanted
it to be today that
clearly is the case although it's
certainly how a lot of people have been
spending their last couple of weeks
isolating because they've been pinged by
the nhs app
but when it comes to what actually
happened today i think
most of us are fairly used to things
changing now even if it is frustrating
but there's a creeping sense from that
press conference that actually there is
a real worry at the heart of downing
street and among scientific advisors
that
there is so much uncertainty now and
coupled that with the fact that now
essentially we all have to make our own
judgments our own choices about how safe
we are to do
certain things and that some people will
feel much freer than others
there is just no way of knowing for the
scientists how high those case rates are
going to go
and subsequently how many people will be
in hospital and how many people will die
the estimation that around a thousand
people a day could be admitted well
that's not as high as we've seen in the
past it's not necessarily as worrying a
place as we have previously been in
but it is still very uncertain and
that's what both jonathan van damme and
patrick valens highlighted repeatedly
today we just don't know yet
and that really is what's feeding into
boris johnson's decisions about
nightclubs and it's just worth taking a
step back because a couple of days ago
everybody thought freedom day meant
freedom to go to a nightclub and you
would be uninhibited you could make your
own choices and
you wouldn't need to necessarily prove
anything now today we know that in
september you will only be able to do
that if you've been double vaccinated
that is a huge shift in tone it's
something that the prime minister
has probably not wanted to do not wanted
to say and it tells you that they are
very worried about what happens in the
winter
if they don't put restrictions like this
on but listen very carefully to what
bryce johnson said in that clip there
he didn't just say nightclubs he said
other large venues were kind of super
spreader events might occur
did that mean football matches a
journalist asked him and the prime
minister avoided answering that question
but it could lead the way to other
restrictions on other types of things
that we want to do in the next couple of
months okay